[موسيقى]
خرجوا من ديارهم حذر الموت لكنه ابى الى
ان يكون رفيق خروجهم الاف من السودانيين
قطعوا ويقطعون دروب الصحراويه الى ليبيا
في رحله قاسيه هربا من النزاعات القبليه
في دارفور او طمعا في تحسين اوضاعهما
المعيشيه او املا في العبور الى اوروبا
غير ان الموتى طارد احلامهم وامالهم واسرع
العديد منهم وقتلهم جوعا وعطشا في صحراء
قاحله ومن بقيت فيه حياه صار سلعه
يتداولها تجار البشر ومهرب والمهاجرين غير
الشرعيين واللاجئين وتعرض لانتهاكات مفزعه
كالابتزاز والاستغلال الجنسي والعمل صخره
وحتى القتل
تقدر المفوضيه العليا لشؤون اللاجئين
اعدادا طالبي اللجوء او اللاجئين المسجلين
لديها من السودانيين به حوالي 15 الفا اي
تقريبا ثلث اجمالي عدد طالبي اللجوء
المسجلين لديها لكن الارقام في ارض واقع
تبدو اكبر في قصتنا السودان ليبيا رحله
الموت
نعيش سودانيات وسودانيين لاجئين في ليبيا
نطلع على مبدا من معاناتهم في تدبير اسباب
حياتهم في ليبيا كما نرصد اوضاعهم
القانونيه حيث تعتبرهم السلطات الليبيه
مهاجرين غير شرعيين كما نبحث مع القائم
بالاعمال السوداني في طرابلس حدود الدعم
الذي تقدمه لهم السفاره السودانيه وكذا
دور المفوضيه العليا لشؤون اللاجئين اما
بقيه القصه فنستكملها مع فتح الله السرير
رئيس اللجنه القانونيه السابق في المجلس
الاعلى للدوله في
ليبيازي باحثه الهجره واللجوء في المرصد
الاورو متوسط لحقوق الانسان
ونسالهما عن امكانيه ضمان الحد الادنى من
المعامله الانسانيه لهؤلاء اللاجئين
حدود الدعم المقدم اليهم من المنظمات
الانسانيه الدوليه
وفاعليه برنامج العوده الطوعيه للاجئين من
السودانيين وغيرهم في ليبيا نشاهد القصه
ونبدا الحوار
في نهايه عام 2017 انتشرت حول العالم صور
مفزعه لمهاجرين يباعون في ليبيا كما لو
انهم مجرد سلع ما اثار موجه غضب عالميه
دفعت الكثير من القاده الاوروبيين
والليبيين الى التعهد باتخاذ اجراءات
حمايه اللاجئين والمهاجرين من التعرض
للاساءه والظروف المهينه الا انه وبعد
مرور ثلاث سنوات من موجه الغضب وفي منتصف
فبراير عام 2021 اظهر مقطع مصور لحظه
العثور على جثث عائله سودانيه ماتت جراء
الجوع والعطش بعد ان علقت في صحراء الكفره
الواقعه جنوب شرق ليبيا اشهر ممرات
الصحراء الليبيه للهجره غير الشرعيه لتلقي
الضوء على الماسي والكوارث التي يتعرض لها
اللاجئون والمهاجرون السودانيون في الطريق
الى ليبيا
اللاجئين
هدفهم في في المقام الاول تحت السنين
اوضاع والمعيشيه وفي السابق كثير من
اللاجئين
وصلوا هربا من ويلات الحرب في دارفور
لدينا حوالي 15 الف سوداني من طالبي
اللجوء او اللاجئين المسجلين في مفوضيه
شؤون اللاجئين في ليبيا من اجمالي 43 الف
طلب لجوه مما يعني ان ثلث اللاجئين او
طالبين لجوء المسجلين لدى مفوضيه شؤون
اللاجئين في ليبيا قادمون من السودان
ذهبنا لمقابله بعض المهاجرين السودانيين
في ليبيا للتعرف على اسباب قيامهم برحلات
هجره غير شرعيه
[موسيقى]
كنت عادي وقد كنت في القريه علينا الحرب
الغربي لهذا بين النار
العرب
[موسيقى]
طبعا شلت اولادي وطلعت طبعا انا ارمله انت
اولادي وطلعت
[موسيقى]
مع الغنم
زوج زوجي وزوج اختي قالت لهم في المخيم
وضاربينهم هم الزوس مع التالي صارت علينا
الظروف بتاعه الحلقه فهد الغبلي وهذا اللي
طلعنا من جنوب دارفور
هربنا لا عرفنا البهائمين لاعرفنا المعز
لا عرفنا شيء خشينا
في المدينه ما عندك وين تسكن وحوش الايجار
الصعبه انت ما عندك من وين تاجر بس
[موسيقى]
الله يبارك فيكم
الناس كثيره يعني
[موسيقى]
عندي هدف انا بدي العب كوره
تتدفق قوافل المهاجرين السودانيين اتجاه
ليبيا بمعرفه شبكات التهريب عبر دروب وطرق
صحراويه تسيطر عليها ميليشيات مسلحه وبعض
القبائل التي تتخذ من عمليات تهريب ونقل
المهاجرين تجاره رائجه تتكسب منها بعد
انهيار مؤسسات الدوله بسبب الانقسام
السياسي والصراع المسلح داخل ليبيا وفق
تقرير الامم المتحده وتجار اللي يعملوا في
تهريب البشر غير الشرعيه يسلك في بعض
الاحيان طرق غير مطروقه ويتجنب نقاط
التفتيش
واماكن تواجد الله القوات الامنيه والقوات
المسلحه والقوات الشرفيه
في بعض المدن ممكن يغرب السودان
ومنها الى الحدود ما بين السودان
وليبيا في المنطقه المثلث في بعض الاحيان
هناك بعض المعلومات انه المهربين البشر
يسلكوا بعض الطرق عبر الكشاف يعبروا
الحدود الى تشاد ومنها حدود ما بين تشاد
وليبيا ناس طبعا بتقول نمشي ليبيا نمشي
ليبيا اخر طبعا الناس من زمان اهل العرب
من زمان بجوليا هي هذا خلاص انا اشيل
صغاري وطلعت جاينا نحن سيارات هذي بنرقص
سيارات قدامنا بنرقص
الطن الغنم بتحت وخدت لنا اللوحه فوق ونحن
قاعدين وقت ما السياره بتقيم فيها ومن
طيبه غبره وواحد ورمالو يحطوا العيش في
الشطائر زي هذيله
بعد هداك ما فيش ميه كلام واحد اغسل يدين
ولا يغسل وشه ولا ما فيش هذا بكره اصلا
حتى الصلاه لما واحد يصلي يتمم يمهم يعني
ما فيش مويه قوي وقمت تتوضا بالمويه طبعا
المويه تقص عليك وبتموت في السهره هذا
الشرطه الاول
15 يوم
[موسيقى]
لحد ما حد الكفره شهر 30 يوم نحن في السهر
شهر او يقل قليلا تلك هي مده الرحله من
غرب السودان الى ليبيا عبر عده خطوط
للتهريب تنطلق من السودان الى الكفره في
الجنوب الشرقي لليبيا اهمها ثلاثه خطوط
بحسب الخريطه التي نشرها مركز نويى
للابحاث عام 2019
مسارات الهجره عبر دروب الصحراء لا تكون
دائما امنه حيث ان المهاجرين يتعرضون
لانتهاكات مفزعه مثل الاستغلال والعنف
الجنسي والاختطاف مقابل فديه والابتزاز
والسخره والقتل غير المشروع بحسب ما ورد
في تقرير لجنه الخبراء المعنيه بليبيا
التي اكدت ازدياد عمليات الاتجار بالبشر
في ليبيا وبحسب ما نشر من صور للتعذيب على
صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي
الجبر خلاني تحملت طبعا غادي ولايه دارفور
قتل
يحتطفوا البنات يعني يلا غالب هاجرت بناتي
بايش اتحملت الطريقه بتاع السفر وصلتني
[موسيقى]
الوصول الى ليبيا بمثابه نهايه وع
ثاء لكنه يمثل بابا تفتح على اثره ابواب
وفصول اخرى من المعاناه اهمها الوضع
القانوني للمهاجر وفقا للقوانين الليبيه
ليبيا دوله الى حد هذه اللحظه لم توقف على
الاتفاقيه الدوليه الخاصه بحمايه اللاجئين
في العالم والمعروفه باتفاقيه 51 رغم انها
قامت بالتوقيع على اتفاقيه 69 الافريقيه
لحمايه اللاجئين في افريقيا
ولمرجعيتها الاساسيه هي الاتفاقيه الدوليه
لعام 51 وبالتالي تتعامل مع كل من هو دخل
الى ارابيها بدون تاشيره دخول وبدون اذن
في وضعيه هجره غير شرعيه وتتعامل مع
السلطات الضبطيه
قانون رقم 19 لعام 2010 المعني بمكافحه
الهجره غير الشرعيه في ليبيا هم المهاجرين
هنا 75
فيهم 35
مستغرين من السبعينات الستينات الثمانينات
موجودين داخل ليبيا هنا اما الاربعين الف
هما مهاجرين شباب ونساء قصدهم يعبروا
المتوسط الى اوروبا وفي الحاله دي لو قبضت
السلطات الليبيه لا يمتلك اقامه ولا يمتلك
دخول فكذا بيسموه مهاجر غير شرعي انت
الخوف الين عند الخوف هذا حاجه ضروري بدنا
نخافوا من النسيج ضروري يعني هذا كمان
حريه صح ولا لا لو لما نشوفوا السياره
بتاعت هجره ماشيه نحن ما نعرفه يعني اي
طار بنقولوا هذه هي نعرفوش السياره يعني
هي سياره عن مخطوط فيها يعني عالم عسكري
نقولوا هذه نخافوا يعني والله الحمد لله
الدنيا عادي
تعرضت في طريق السجن هذا مش هذا دون
ارادتي نطلب من ربي ربنا يعينه وربنا
يساعدني ان شاء الله وفقا للقوانين
الليبيه يعد السودانيون الذين دخلوا الى
الاراضي الليبيه دون اذن مهاجرين غير
شرعيين تطبق عليهم القوانين الليبيه التي
تجرم تواجدهم على اراضيها وتقوم السلطات
باحتجازهم في مراكز احتجاز في ظروف مروعه
كما وصفها الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيريش الذي دعا الى اغلاق تلك
المراكز بعد ان تعرض مركز تاجوراء شرقي
طرابلس للقصف اثناء الحرب ما ادى الى مقتل
اكثر من 50 لاجئا ومهاجرا لتزداد معاناه
المهاجرين السودانيين سواء بسبب تجريم
اقامتهم دون اذن شرعي او بسبب عدم وجود
حمايه قانونيه للمهاجرين
كما تعلمون الذي لديه خصوصيه في التعامل
لا يتم التواصل مع اللاجئ الا عن طريق
المفوضيه الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين او
بطبعا لا يوختياره في بعض الاحيان بعض
اللاجئين السودانيين يحتاجوا
استخراج وثائق ثبوتيه اصدار توكيل
فالابواب مفتوحه يعني القلوب مفتوحه قبل
الابواب لكل سوداني لاجي او غير لاجئ او
غير مقيم او غير مقيم
مفتوحه ويتم
الاستقبال بكل احترام وتقدير والاجراء
ويسر جدا كل الاجراءات مشيت السفاره
السودانيه
الاطفال ما عندهم اور
لاولادنا بناويكي الاوراق ما اعطوني شيء
ابوهم الوالد طبعا ابوهم متوفي وعمهم
متوفي قلت لهم انتم تعرفوني اليوم قديش
وقت معاكم وانا ماشي وجاية
يعني معاملتهم كان معامله معينه معامله
بالشخ والله السفاره دي ما شئت
وصفتها لما
ساعدني
[موسيقى]
لا مشيت
لا تتوقف معاناه اللاجئين السودانيين عند
الوضع القانوني ففيما يخص اللاجئين الذين
يريدون الاستقرار في ليبيا عليهم البحث عن
وسيله للرزق لتبدا معاناه جديده
المثقف المتعلم مثلا كمحاسب مهندس دكتور
عنده الفرص بتاعه العمل هم الغليل فيهم من
المتعلم اعمالهم هم مثلا في الحكى اعمالهم
مثلا اشتغلوا يوميات
ينظفوايات
يشتغلوا في الشوارع
سنشتغل في البخور ونشتغل في اللحكات تحت
المشروع
المسواك متابع الجمعه والخميس والاثنين
والنصيب عن ربك تلقى الخمسين تلقى العشرين
تلقى 30 تلقى الاربعين تلقى العشره كل شيء
بالنصيب
والله لما جيت طرابلس طبعا لما كنت في سفر
بلقط في الخروج شادي في الرابي شادي ما
عنديش شغل تاني اشتغل في الراب هذا بس
الشوال بيجيب لي مرات اربعه دينار مرات
خمسه دينار هو الله هي اللي جار صعب
والطعام صعب لما يجي صاحب الحوش ينظر في
امرك ينظر في حالك
نتحاسب معك يوم مع الزوج يلا اطلع علي من
هالحوش اطلع لي منها
الحوشة يعني شو بقول لك الحكايه صعبه يعني
الحياه مره وليدي
يخوض اللاجئون الحالمون ببلوغ شواطئ
اوروبا معاناه الانتظار بين حطام القوارب
في انتظار دورهم لعبور البحر المتوسط في
رحله يواجهون فيها خطر الموت غرقا او
الاعاده القصريه الى مراكز الاحتجاز
الليبيه المموله من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي
اضافه الى المساعدات الكبيره التي تقدم
لتعزيز قدرات خفر السواحل الليبيه على
اعتراض سبيل اللاجئين والمهاجرين في عرض
البحر في اطار مذكره تفاهم وقعت بين ليبيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي للحد من الهجره غير
الشرعيه نحو اوروبا تعرف باسم العمليه
صوفيا
واول مره هنا في طرابلس في السودانيين
يعني السودانيين كثيرا
اعطوني الرقم بتاع المهرب اتصلت عليهم
الرحله الاولى وبعد كده
بروحي
قديش فلوس
يعني مرات تقريبا انا بدي شهر شهرين وعادي
24 ساعه يوم بس 24 ساعه ويرجعون اللي كل
اللاجئين الموجودين في ليبيا غير معترف
بهم من قبل السلطات الليبيه
كمهاجرين غير شرعيين وبالتالي
يتعرضون الى الاحتجاز داخل المراكز اللي
هو في هذه المراكز هناك العديد من
الانتهاكات التي تحصل لهؤلاء
اللاجئين السفر تقوم بزيارات اسبوعيه وفي
بعض الاحيان مرتين في الاسبوع مسجون
الليبيه
ولمراكز الايواء ومراكز هجره غير الشرعيه
لن تتخلف الحكومه السودانيه عن واجبها
ومسؤوليه تتجاهل اللاجئين السودانيين
والموجودين في ليبيا
الشفه على الصغار اما الكبار لازم يترحل
لدولته لانه لا يمتلك دخول شرعي ولا يمتلك
فهو بيترحل للدوله السودانيه
ليست عضوا في اتفاقيه
1951 الخاصه باوضاع اللاجئين فهي لا تعتبر
نفسها دوله لجوء ونحن نحترم اختيار ليبيا
كدوله مستقله في انها لا تعتبر هؤلاء
اللاجئين
طلعت من النوم البطاقه قبل اربع سنين ولا
هو خمس سنين ادوني 750 ناديك تاني ما
اعطوني حاجه اليوم خمس سنين ولا هو سته
سنين مش عارف ما اعطاني نعم سجلت
اربع سنوات ولا ثلاث سنوات من اول الدون
و400 وفي الاخير ادونا 600
حتى من الباب ما بدخلوه في ناس مريضه انا
تكلمتها مع المديره بتاعتهم عشان هي توصل
لهم العلاج ما ادتني
وبالنسبه بتعمل تقييم للسودانيين ونحن
نديكم اكل وشرب وما في شيء يعني ممكن في
مره ان مهمه مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين فيما
يخص اللاجئين وطالبي اللجوء في ليبيا هي
التنسيق مع السلطات الليبيه حول اوضاع
اللاجئين وضمان حمايتهم وتقديم الحلول لهم
في ليبيا في ليبيا
يتطلع اللاجئون السودانيون في ليبيا الى
موقف دولي جدي بالتنسيق مع الحكومتين
السودانيه والليبيه يضمن حقوقهم التي
كفلها لهم القانون الانساني بدمجهم في
مجتمعاتهم المضيفه وتوفير سبل العيش لهم
وفق معايير اللجوء الدوليه لاسيما في ظل
ظروف استثنائيه دفعتهم لمغادره بلادهم
ارحب بضيفي الكريمين من طرابلس فتح الله
السريري وهو رئيس اللجنه القانونيه السابق
في المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا
وارحب كذلك بالضيفه من روما ميكيلا بوليسي
وهي باحثه الهجره واللجوء في المرصده
الاورو متوسطيه لحقوق الانسان اهلا بكما
ابدا معك سيد فتح الله ما عرضناه في قصتنا
ربما هو ينقل جزء بسيط من معاناه كبيره
ووضع تصفه تقارير حقوقيه بالصادم لماذا
على حد علمك
لماذا تتعامل معهم السلطات الليبيه بهذا
الشكل
تحيه لك وللمشاهديك الكرام الحقيقه حقيقه
موضوع الهجره غير الشرعيه وغير المشروعه
هو موضوع معقد لدى كل الدول
المستقره
والتعامل مع السلطات الدول معها ايضا
بتفاوت وبنسب
متفاوته
القانون رقم 19 ل 2010 في الماده 11 من
يفرض على السلطات الليبيه التعامل مع
هؤلاء التعامل بما يحفظ كرامتهم الانسانيه
وادميتها وعدم مصادره اي منقولات او اموال
لديهم لكن كما لا يخفى على احد بان الان
ليبيا تمر بظروف صعبه انقسام سياسي مؤسسات
منقسمه بلاد شاسعه تعد قاره ممكن من حيث
المساحه الجغرافيه قد تساوي المملكه
المتحده البريطانيه اربع مرات وفي فرصه
ثلاث مرات الكفر التي تتحدثون عنها تشكل
مساحه الجغرافيه كبيره
التاسعه ليبيا كقاره من الصعب بالضبط هذه
الحدود
وتحتاج الى امكانيات يعني كبيره جدا
فهذه ظروف الدوله الليبيه الان الصعبه
التي تعيشها الان تجعل من هذه المعامله
يعني بطبيعه الحال لن تكون في افضل
الاحوال
بالنسبه للجوع والعطش وعدم وجود المسكن
حتى لدى الليبيين
الوطنيين ومن ثم وانت كمان ظاهره الهجره
هذه هي ظاهره طبيعيه متعدده الاسباب نتيجه
الجوع الفقر النزاعات ظلم السياسي ومن ثم
يعني ليبيا من حيث القانون نظمت هذه
المساله والزمت السلطات بالتعامل معهم
وفقا امكانيات طبعا الامكانيات كما قلت
ليبيا الان الحقيقه لو تسالي كل السلطات
لا تجد الدعم الكافي
لواء الاعداد الكبيره من المهاجرين و
ليبيا كما يعلم الجميع هي دوله عبور ليس
دوله مص الاطلاق ومن ثم يعني من ياتي
اليها باعداد كبيره جدا حتى دول كبيره
والمستقره من ضمنها الدول الاوروبيه
ترجع هؤلاء الاشخاص ثم ان هؤلاء الاشخاص
حتى بتقارير او باشياء اسميه من يرحل الى
بلد بعد شهر يعود الى نبي من جديد نتيجه
الامكانيات وايضا نعم ساعود اليك نسمع
الان سيده ميكيلا
انت كيف تقيمين اوضاع اللاجئين والمهاجرين
غير القانونيين في
ليبيا وهل تتفقين مع ما قاله السيد فتح
الله الذي لا يرى بوجود تجاوزات خطيره
تمارس بحقهم
شكرا جزيلا اذا في بادي الامر اريد ان
اوضح ان هناك ليس هناك ما يسمى
بمهاجرين غير قانونيين هم اشخاص ليس لديهم
الوثائق القانونيه لكن ليس هناك شيء نسميه
بمهاجر غير قانوني نتحدث عن مصطلح اشخاص
ليس لديهم الوثائق
القانونيه خصوصا عندما يتعلق الامر
باللاجئين هؤلاء الاشخاص لابد لا يتعرضوا
لحالات تتعلق بالتعذيب وما الى ذلك فيما
يخص الوضع في ليبيا هناك عدد من الاشخاص
الذين يتعرضون الى الكثير من حالات
الانتهاكات الانسانيه الممنهجه ويتعرضون
الى اشياء متعدده مثل الاستغلال الجنسي
وكذلك الابتزاز والسخره والعمل القصري
وكذلك الاحتجاز
وكذلك انتهاكات تتم في مراكز الاحتجاز
الرسميه وغير الرسميه وهذا الامر يجعلهم
في حلقه
لا تنتهي من الانتهاكات انتقالا من مكان
الى اخر من خلال جهات تابعه لدول واطراف
غير تابعه لدول وتستمر هذه المعاناه
بالنسبه لهم سيد فتح الله استمعت الى كلام
سيده ميكيلا الكثير من الانتهاكات التي
تمارس بحق اللاجئين
لاستغلال الجنسي لاحتجاز القصري لاعتداء
وامور عديده اخرى صحيح ان ليبيا لم توقع
على الاتفاقيه الدوليه الخاصه بحمايه
اللاجئين لكنها وقعت على الاتفاقيه
الافريقيه بهذا الشان لماذا لا تفي
بالتزاماتها الانسانيه
على الاقل
الليبي عندها قوانين كما قلت من ضمن
وهذا موضوع انساني اكثر من كورن اتفاقيه
والتزامات قانونيه خاصه للمجتمع الليبيا
مجتمع ومسلمة ومجتمع متكافل ويعني مجتمع
مترابط لكن ما فيش معيار معين لهذه
المعامله في هذه الظروف الاستثنانيه خاصه
حتى في دول اوروبا لا يعاملون انسانيا حتى
في الدول الاخرى المستقره لا يعامل
الانسانيه ومرفوضين التراهم في ولايه
تقارن بيعمل صور بينه وبين المكسيك فحتى
الدوله زي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اقوى دوله في العالم اقتصادا وامكانيات
تواجه في هذه المشكله لكن التجاوزات هذه
انا لا اقول بينها غير موجوده هذه موجوده
حتى ضد الليبيه احيانا فهذه التجاوزات
الجنائيه
موجوده ولكن غير مقبوله اجتماعيا ومن حيث
السلطه وبالعكس يعني حتى يعني معامله
المهاجرين القانون الليبي نظرا للمهاجر
بغض النظر عن التوصيف القانوني من
القانوني هذه مسائل يعني صراحه لما تجيل
الواقع تختلف حتى القانون 19 2010 الضحيه
هو المهاجر وان يعني والعقوبات القاسيه
كلها على الليبيين الذين يستغلون هؤلاء
الاشخاص لدرجه توصل الى السجن المؤبد لمن
يكون سبب في وفاه يعني هؤلاء المهاجرين
غير الشرعين وهم بطبيعه الحال ايضا
يواجهوا في ظروف قاسيه في بلدانهم والا
لما لجاوا لهذه الطرق الغير شرعيه والغير
مشروعه والغير قانونيه سماها كما تشاء ومن
تم التجاوزاتهم موجوده في كل يعني دول
العالم وليبيا كما قلنا خاصه في هذا الوضع
الاستثنائي وهذه الاعداد الكبيره لكن
السلطات تحاول جاهده بقدر الامكان وعدم
وجود للاسف الاتفاقيات الدوليه لا تلزم
ليبيا ببعض الواجبات ايضا تفرض واجبات على
الدول الاخرى فيمن من حيث المساعدات من
حيث التامين لاجهزه المراقبه للحدود من
حيث الترحيل هؤلاء المهاجرين من حيث
اطعامهم وشرابهم من حيث
تحملها دوليبيه ومن وعن الدوله الليبيه
السؤال اللافت ان التقارير الحقوقيه
توجه اتهامات الى الاجهزه الامنيه الليبيه
وليس الى الميليشيات المسلحه كيف يمكن
تفسير ذلك
يعني الاجهزه الامنيه في ليبيا كما قلنا
يعني في وضع غير مستقر وعارف الانقسام
اللي موجود وهذه التصنيفات يعني غير دقيقه
ايضا في هذا الاطار لكن يعني هل اجلس
الامنيه يعني هل السلطات الليبيه والحكومه
الليبيه توجه يعني بهذا المعنى الذي يساق
من السيده وطرحت السؤال اذا كان الحكومه
الليبيه توجه سلطاتها للانتقام او للتشفي
او لتعليم
الاحتجاز والتي توصف بالاسوا على الاطلاق
وهي تحت مسؤوليه وزاره الداخليه اليس كذلك
هي غير مقبوله احنا كما قلنا فيها تجاوزات
لكن دائما لماذا لا ينظر للجانب الاخر
دائما التركيز على التجاوزات دون الجوانب
الاخرى وان كل مسؤول يعتدي على هؤلاء
سيعاقب وهناك جيئات مسؤوله
سيعاقبها هؤلاء للاشخاص وكما قلنا توصل
العقوبه الى السجن المؤبد انا لا اعتقد ان
وجود قانون في غير الدوله الليبيه انا
تفرض او تعاقب الليبي الذي يسيء معامله
هؤلاء الاشخاص الى درجه السجن المؤبد وانه
نظر التشريعات الليبيه التصرفات غير
مضبوطه في العالم يعني كلها صراحه لا نريد
لا توجد في العالم دوله مثاليه تعامل
المهاجرين غير الشرعيين حتى الدول
الاوروبيه لا تعامل العرب ولا تعامل
المسلمين ويتعامل غيرها من اللي يدخلوا
دخول غير شرعي اتحول انسانيه مثل
المواطنين
حتى الدول الاوروبيه
هناك الكثير من اخذ عليها في طريقه
التعامل مع المهاجرين اليس من المتحف
تحميل لي مسؤوليه اكبر
مما يمكن ان تتحملها هناك اعداد هائله من
اللاجئين تلجا اليها هناك حدود شاسعه
ومفتوحه والظروف التي تمر بها ليبيا ليست
بظروف المثاليه
نعم الهجره هي من المواضيع الساخنه
بالنسبه لكل الدول بما في ذلك الاتحاد
الاوروبي والليبيا في الوضع الحالي هي
يغيب عليه عنها القانون وتطبيق القانون في
الكثير من الاحيان وبالتالي هذا يؤثر على
وضع اللاجئين
والمهاجرين لكن في الان ذاته ليس
الوضع نفسه في اوروبا لانه في ليبيا فان
الانتهاكات الموجوده هي واسعه النطاق
ممنهجه بشكل كبير جدا وبالتالي هذا يعتبر
جزء من الاطار القانوني الذي
يجرب المهاجرين ويقوم
باستغلال
جعلهم يستغلون
بمستويات وصلت الى عتبه اعتبارها
جرائم ضد الانسانيه وبالتالي هذا الوضع هو
مختلف و السياق مختلف حسب النائب العام
التابع للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وبالتالي
هذا ادى الى مشاكل كبيره نعم ليبيا تواجه
مشاكل كبيره عندما يتعلق الامر بالتعامل
مع
المهاجرين وهذا بسبب تجريم هذا الوضع
واعتبار ان القضيه هي قضيه انسانيه وامنيه
لهذه الاسباب فاننا لدينا عدد من
الاتفاقيات والمعدات والمساعدات
والتدريبات التي توفر لخفر السواحل التي
لابد ان تستخدم ويتم الاستفاده منها
للمساعده للافراح بحقوقهم
ما الفائده من كل هذه الاتفاقيات اذا كان
الواقع مرير الذين يفقدون ويموتون في عرض
البحر الابيض المتوسط اعدادهم بالمئات
ودول اوروبيه عديده متورطه في ذلك اليس
كذلك
نعم اتفق تماما الاتحاد الاوروبي كذلك
لديه مسؤوليه كبيره فيما يخص ما يحصل في
ليبيا والسبب وراء وجود اتفاق ما بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاعضاء خصوصا
ايطاليا مع ليبيا هذه الاتفاقات ترمي ان
يكون هناك احتواء للوضع وكذلك خفض عدد
الاشخاص الذين يصلون الى الحدود وكذلك
العمل على الوضع فيما يخص الضفه الافريقيه
من البحر الابيض المتوسط وحتى لا يكون
هناك انتهاكات تتم في هذه المراكز مراكز
الاحتجاز وكذلك حتى لا يكون هناك حالات
عنف وانتهاكات في الاتحاد الاوروبي لابد
ان يكون هناك اغتنام الفرصه من اجل توفير
كل الدعم وحتى
ووقف اي مساعدات في حال ما اذا كان هناك
انتهاكات لابد ان تكون هناك مسارات
قانونيه بالنسبه لطالب اللجوء والمهاجرين
الذين يحتاجون للوصول الى الضفه الاخرى
بما ان قصتنا اليوم عن اللاجئين
السودانيين في ليبيا هل لدى الجهه الرسميه
احصاء دقيق عن اعدادهم ان كان داخل مراكز
الاحتجاز او خارجها او كذلك فيما يتعلق
باوضاع اللاجئين الذين ذهبوا الى ليبيا
منذ السبعينيات القرن الماضي ما هي
اوضاعهم كذلك
طبعا هي فيما يتعلق بالسلطات بالتاكيد انه
عندها الاحصائيات انا لا تحضرني الان لكن
العالم كله والانظمه القانونيه اي شخص
يدخل البلد بطريقه غير قانونيه ووضع غير
قانوني ومن تم حتى القانون هذا في الماده
11 او ماده اي شخص يدخل الاراضي الليبيه
ولا يساوي وضعه خلال شهرين يعتبر مهاجر
غير شرعي وحتى في الدول الاوروبيه نفس
القصه في دول العالم كلها وانا كيف عامله
اذا القانون لم يشرع ولم يبيح بل يعني كما
قلنا يعني سن اقصى العقوبات ودائما النصوص
القانونيه سواء اتفاقيات دوليه او نص وطني
دائما النصوص تختلف عن الواقع هناك هو
كبيره بين الاتفاقيات الدوليه والنصوص
القانونيه والواقع في كل دول
العالميه ليست استثناء في هذا الموضوع
المهاجرين حتى السلطات المسفراتهم لا
تتعامل معهم ثم هناك حاجز ليبي ايضا وهناك
قد تكون هناك خطوط اوروبيه وغيرها
المهاجرين في ليبيا وهذه مشكله هذه
السلطات الليبيه ثم انا الاتحاد الاوروبي
ودول الاوروبيه لماذا لا تبحث عن اساس
المشكله وهي الجوع والفقر وتعمل استثمارات
في الاراضي الافريقيه او دول المصدر حتى
يبقى هؤلاء لان بالتفكير البسيط للانسان
ان كيف الانسان يموت هو من اجل انه يعيش
ان يصل الى مكان للعيش لا يعني ذلك او لا
يبرر الجرائم التي ترتكب ضدهم تقول ان
المهاجر غير القانوني هو غير قانوني لكن
هل يجب معاملته كمجرم
كسجين يعاقب على ظروف ماساويه دفعته الى
الهجره لا يعتبر ضيف عندكم في ليبيا
هذا قولا واحدا انه لا يجب ان تمارس عليه
اي اشكال عنف ولا
يعتبر مجرم ولا هذه قولا واحدا لكن كما
قلت للتجاوزات الان موجوده وهم ايضا حتى
المهاجرين هل مستويات اتفاقيه هل انت
تستطيع ان تقولي كل من دخل بلادك هو غير
مجرم وقد يكون عنده سلوك اجرامي فهي مسائل
نسبيه احنا قولا واحدا قانونا وشرعا وعرفا
اجتماعيا يعني عدم يعني قبول التعدي على
اي شخص لكن نعتبر الضيف الضيف ياتي بطرق
مشروعه ما فيش ضيف يدخل الباب او لبيتك
بطريقه غير شرعيه وتقول يضيف لكن لا يعني
هذا عامله بطريقه بس احنا نعمله في وفق
الامكانيات اللي موجوده يعني عندنا
التجاوزات موجوده قلت لك حتى ضد المواطنين
في كل دول العالم ولكن ليست معناها ان
نبررها ولا نجيزها لا احنا نعاقبها هذه
السلطات تخضع كما قلنا تحت طائله القانون
فيما يمكن تجاوزه لكن انت احيانا هذه
الاعداد الكبيره جدا
في في المراقبه تعالج مشاكل كذا بس اي هي
تستعمل فيها والكثير من الدول تستعمل فيها
ورقه سياسيه طبعا الهجره في كل دول العالم
صراحه يعني الان دول العالم كثيره تطلق
المهاجرين مقصود على بعض الدول للابتزاز
السياسي لاسال للسيده طبعا
الهجره
لا تنجح الا بوجود
شبكات
للهجره للتجاره بالبشر لا سيما فيما يتعلق
بهؤلاء السودانيين الذين يذهبون الى ليبيا
هل لديكم معطيات حول هذه الشبكات من
يدعمها تحت اي مظله تعمل كذلك ومن يحميها
بالنسبه للشبكات تهريب البشر هي عابره
للحدود ولسوء الحظ ليس هناك بيانات
ومعلومات كثيره بشان هذه الشبكات هذه
تعتبر شبكات غير قانونيه نعم هناك بعض
التحقيقات الجاريه والتي تنمو من خلال
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه من خلال
الانتربول وكذلك بعض الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي التي تبحث في هذه
الشبكات التي تربط ما بين السودان وليبيا
وكذلك الدول الاخرى جنوب الصحراء مثل
النيجر التي تعبر الصحراء لتصل الى هذه
المناطق لكن صعوبه بمكان ان نقوم بتعقب
مصادر هذه الشبكات شبكات التهريب التي
تجري اذا عمليه التهريب وعمليه الاتجار
بالبشر يتم
تعزيزها من لنظام كامل وذلك من خلال بعض
السياسات التي ربما تجعل المهاجرين صعبا
للغايه وبالتالي يحاولون الدخول هذه
الحدود من خلال هذه
الشبكات هؤلاء المهربين وكذلك الذي يقومون
بالاتجار بالبشر يقومون بتيسير العبور
لانه ليس هناك اي مسارات قانونيه بالنسبه
لبعض الاشخاص ليصلوا ويعبروا من ليبيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي نعم يصلون الى ليبيا
وليس لديهم تاشيرات تمكنهم من الدخول بشكل
قانوني ونفس الشيء ينطبق على اوروبا ليس
هناك امكانات بالنسبه لاولاء الاشخاص
ليسلكوا المسار القانوني الدخول الى
السفاره الحصول على التاشيره او سيمه
الدخول للدخول الى ايطاليا او اي دوله
اخرى في الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي هؤلاء
الاشخاص هم مجبرون ليقومون ليقوموا
بالعبور عبر
بحر ويكونون تحت يد من يستغلونهم من جهات
تهريب البشر وشبكات التهريب وتنتهي الرحله
في بعض في الكثير من المرات
بالموت لكن في المقابل هناك من يدعو
ويطالب بايجاد حلول لهذه الهجره من خلال
العوده الى اوطانهم ماكين حامد اعتراب
والامين العام لجهاز تنظيم شؤون
السودانيين في الخارج دعا الى تكاتف
الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه لمعالجه مشكله
الهجره غير الشرعيه واوضح ان الخرطوم
بالتعاون مع منظمه الهجره الدوليه تمكنت
عبر برنامج العوده الطوعيه من اعاده اكثر
من 7000 سوداني هاجروا بصوره غير شرعيه
خلال سنوات الخمس الماضيه واوضح ان
مجموعات من هؤلاء المهاجرين اتخذوا ليبيا
معبرا لهم الى دول اخرى كالمغرب والنيجر
نستمع الى مقاله
احنا من 2017 لحد 2022 نعيد اكثر من 7000
مهاجر شرعيه
فيها بعض يعني عشان نقدر نعمل معالجات
للموده طبيعيه مساهمه فيها الخارجيه
السودانيه ايضا اخواننا في السفاره
المنظمه الدوليه وكل الجهاز اعتصيله
بعد ما نعيد ونمكن يكونوا هنا بتعمل له
مثلا تاع التامين صحي بالاضافه للسكن
وبندوهن يمكن يكون مبالغ ما كبيره لمشاريع
صغيره بحيث ان نقدر نندمجوا في مجتمعات
وبنقدر نوصله لحتى المناطق الحنه في
الولايات المختلفه جانب اخر ايضا سعينا مع
المنظمه بحيث انه ايضا كلها يعني في اطار
سليم اجتماعيه تقدر تقدم بعض الخدمات
التساعد المنطقه نفسها اللي هي يمكن يكون
فيها اعداد اكبر ودي تحديدا يمكن يكون
مقدره فبالتالي بالضروره نكون في بعض
المنظمه الدوليه وبعض الجهات نحن من طريق
فان يكون في تقدم بعض الخدمات اللي بتساعد
على استدامه
للمرحله ثانيه اعود الى سيده للحديث على
برنامج العوده الطوعيه الى اي مدى يمكن
القول انها بالفعل طوعيه ام هي قصريه
وتاتي في ظروف صعبه للغايه بالنسبه لهؤلاء
المهاجرين
حسنا
نعم من الصعب ان نتحدث عن برامج العوده
الطوعيه عندما يكون القرار هو بسبب فقدان
الامل هم عاده يجبرون على قبول مثل هذه
القرارات وذلك للهروب من الانتهاكات التي
يتعرضون لها وكذلك الوضع القصري والصعب
الذي يتعرضون له في مراكز الاحتجاز
وبالتالي هذا يجبرهم على العوده الطوعيه
عمليه العوده الطوعيه التي ترتيب من قبل
السودانيين هي ليست طواعيه تماما وهنا
اتحدث عن السداديين بشكل خاص
وحتى يتم اعادتهم الى بلدانهم بلدانهم
وعندما نتحدث عن
الجهات التي تتم عودتها حسب المنظمه
الهجره الدوليه
الجنسيه ربما الاكثر تعرضا لمثل هذا
البرنامج هم الجنسيه السودانيه وبالتالي
يجبرون على العوده وبالتالي هذا يؤدي الى
عبء اقتصادي ونفسي واجتماعيه يجعلهم اكثر
هشاشه مما كانوا عليها طيب اعود اليك سيد
فتح الله السلطات الليبيه في نوفمبر
الماضي اعلنت ترحيل 230 مهاجر من ليبيا
الى مصر والسودان وتشاد كذلك في اطار ما
يعرف
بالبرنامج العوده الطوعيه لكن في ظروف
وصفت من قبل منظمات حقوقيه بانها ظروف غير
عاديه والعوده كانت قصريه ولم يتمكن هؤلاء
من الحصول على اي مساعده قانونيه لماذا
تلجا السلطات
الى هذا الخيار
تتهرب من هذه المصاريف وهذه الشركات
التهريب شبكات عبر وطنيه يعني دوليه رؤوس
التهريب والشركات التهريب حسب المراصد
الليبيه والصليبيه اغلبهم اجانب غير غير
ليبيين من دول الجوار ومن غيرها واحيانا
صار في احتراف في هذه الشركات ان احيانا
تطلب في مواصفات معينه من الاشخاص من حيث
اللون ومن حيث
الجسم ومن حيث الامكانيات وفي اوقات محدده
فلمسائل المسائل اصبحت يعني فيها منظمه
لانها مكاسب يعني كبيره لكن الهجره طوعيه
يعني روضه من احد يعود لنفس الشيء اللي
هرب منه لكن لابد احنا كدوله اوروبيه ودول
مستقره والتي لا تريد ان تبحث عن الاسباب
وتحاول ان تعالجها اذا كان انت معالجه
السبب يعني صعب انك انت تقضي على هذه
الظاهره اللي هي طبيعي انسانيه نعم
كذا مثل ما قال السيد فتح الله هؤلاء
يرحلون من ليبيا ثم يعودون اليها على امل
اذهب الى اوروبا الدول الاوروبيه التي
تغلق ابوابها امامهم وينتهي بهم المطاف
موتى في البحر لكن ماذا عن مسارات الحل
اين يكمن
الحل ومن يتحمل مسؤوليه ايجاد وتنفيذ هذه
الحلول
هي مطلوبه الحلول هي كثيره ومطلوبه من
السلطات الليبيه وكذلك من الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي لابد
ان يعلق اي عمليه تعاون قد تؤدي الى
احتوائي هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين هم في مراكز
الاحتجاز حتى لا يتعرضوا الى اي انتهاكات
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاعضاء لابد ان
يفتحوا مسارات امنه بالنسبه للاشخاص وكذلك
ان يحسنوا برامج الاجلاء والاخلاء لان
ليبيا لا تعتبر دوله امنه بالنسبه للاجئين
والمهاجرين الليبيون لابد ان يوقفوا كل
الانتهاكات التي يتم ارتكابها والتي يتعرض
اليها طالب اللجوء وكذلك المهاجرون لابد
ان تكون هناك تحقيقات يتم القيام بها فيما
يخص الجرائم جرائم ضد الانسانيه التي
ترتكب ولابد ان رفع تجريم مثل هذه
الممارسات ولابد كذلك ان يتم المصادقه على
اتفاقيه
وان يسمح للمهاجرين بان يعملوا ان يحصلوا
على التاشيره حتى يقوم بذلك بشكل نظامي
ولا يتم استغلالهم في عملهم عندما يصلون
الى ليبيا هذه الادوات ربما قد تكون مفيده
وحتى نوقف الافلات من العقاب الذي يتم
خصوصا بعد الانتهاكات التي تمارس ضدها
هؤلاء المهاجرين شكرا جزيلا لك السيده
ميكيلا بولييزي باحثه الهجره واللجوء في
المرصد الاورو متوسط
لحقوق الانسان
وكذلك اشكر ضيفنا من طرابلس فتح الله
السريري رئيس اللجنه القانونيه السابق في
المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا
وبهذا مشاهدينا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام
هذا البرنامج للقصه بقيه الى لقاء جديد مع
بقيه لقصه جديده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]